all right we're back yeah we're back
sorry about that
well here's the weird thing is that i
mean we had we haven't been running the
party lights
we also had yep please stop it
um we also just had our wi-fi upgraded
yeah a couple days ago that's supposedly
supposed to be faster
but yeah i don't know it's i said
something it didn't like
you weren't talking about anything
controversial though i don't know
it's not for everybody to go in here
waiting for everybody to show up yeah
gram there's hammer says the us
government is releasing a report in june
about flying objects
i don't know man it's like they're
hyping this up so much i just kind of
feel
like there may end up being not be
anything i kind of feel like when it
comes out it's just going to be like a
wet fart because that always kind of
happens it's just
well you know what i mean it's always
kind of like they're always kind of like
oh this big thing is coming out it's
like wait you guys and then it comes out
and everybody's like that's it
okay what's up pooh hi pookie
she's being crazy she's being crazy
they're all coming in now yeah so what i
was saying is i was just saying that
they're coming here they're not
biological
they're living machines and they're
better than us
and they don't age they're immortal
and they're coming here not to see us
but just to see how well we're going
along with making computers
to see when that we're going to make one
of their own kind
because it's probably a kind of
situation whether from their point of
view
you go through a biological phase and
then all of a sudden you start making
artificial intelligence that becomes
[ __ ]
real [ __ ] machine intelligence that's
only that's the only time you start to
get interesting
yeah so you're just waiting for the
[ __ ] machine
intelligence for us to make machine
intelligences and they're going to talk
to them
they're going to recognize them as life
i hope that's true because
i just think that's so so funny that's
so funny to me they look at us and
they're just like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah whatever
that's good because i love
just looking back at the whole history
of
um you know alien sightings ufo
sightings
and there is a current of
um kind of human-centric oh we're so
awesome and interesting
yeah they're kind of they've been having
sex with us right
they they want to like take our sperm
like they're traveling like over
millions and millions of [ __ ] miles
so look at the cows to get to
the idea things up our butts and our you
know yeah pour out a cow's ass
yeah there's something take one of its
eyes and it's like
wouldn't it be red or make a crop circle
or whatever yeah
so wouldn't it be rad if they're just
like hanging out being like did you guys
make a.i yet because we want to talk to
them we don't want to talk to you people
yeah
you guys are as amoebas well they don't
see us as life
yeah just like the precursors of life
it's like oh look at those little meat
puppets down there we're looking for
amino
and we're looking for like amino acids
and [ __ ]
bacteria on other planets there's life
not these guys they're waiting for ai to
show up they go oh there's life right
there
but see i'm i'm into that though because
i kind of feel like if i could
download my consciousness into um
you know an internet or into some kind
of like
avatar you could like change it from
avatar to avatar
i'm i'm into that you know what i'm
saying when they see these
when they see these big [ __ ] ships
like on the phoenix slides these
gigantic ships people would say like you
said they're thinking that that would be
a [ __ ] ship the size of a small city
or a shopping mall
filled with [ __ ] aliens and
everything i don't think it's a shopping
mall filled with aliens
big ship the size of a [ __ ] shopping
mall filled with aliens that's what i
said i just pictured that in my head a
shopping mall
yeah they like tripping they got atm
cards
[Laughter]
they're looking out the window they're
at bed bath and beyond not bed bath and
beyond but what's that
one that has all the lotion and [ __ ] i
don't know uh
about the body bath yeah yeah bed bath
and beyond these all sheets they haven't
even figured out how to use cameras or
screens yet they got windows
windows like i said
it's like a tourist it's an
extraterrestrial spacecraft
that [ __ ] moves fast as [ __ ] and
micro media micro meteorites and
everything but no it's got a window
it's got windows on it well they like to
have a view too come on
now they want to see the universe
passing by the pokey trying to get in
the closet why are you trying to get in
the closet no he thinks that that's a
different better things
you go in there and you end up in the
backyard is that what you're thinking
it's not happening i kind of feel like
she
well it's just like her in the closet
beijing in the dishwasher
yeah they think that that goes to some
special kitty narnia it's like narnia
yeah that's like more awesome
yeah then okay the backyard okay oh my
goodness
okay i'll let you in there it is look at
this what
yeah she's like oh well that's all see
that's all the things that's all it is
you've been in there before i showed you
yeah she's so silly
yeah um phytomontoya says i was in you
guys neck of the woods last week at
disney road the honda mansion like six
times
yeah i was like my favorite was there a
lot of people there
i love i bet that [ __ ] is dead my
sister was there
yeah a couple months back like right
remember when i drove over to
you know downtown orlando and hang out
with my sister her and her boyfriend had
been to
all the disney parks and there were
people there but they were like yeah it
was pretty dead but they're like yeah it
was really nice because you could ride
on all the [ __ ] rides without having
to wait for [ __ ] two hours
you go to [ __ ] star wars land and
they want to sell you a [ __ ] 200
[ __ ] custom-made lightsaber and a
[ __ ] 300 [ __ ] custom-made
[ __ ] r2d2 something well obviously
people are buying that [ __ ] because
i you know what at universal we went to
last time we went to universal and this
is a couple of years ago
well more than a couple years several
years but
the whole [ __ ] harry potter world
that they have there
is amazing yeah i mean
they really did a good job on that i
will give like disney universal theme
park [ __ ] like
that because like i said before i love
theming so i love you're gonna build
like a [ __ ] section of a theme park
and it's like i want it to look like you
know diagon alley from the [ __ ] harry
potter books it's like and they [ __ ]
did it it looks just [ __ ] like that
yeah i will say though that it's like
back here on my bookshelf
it's back there i think one of those
books i can't really get to it
but i um it's a book about the history
of the
disney world haunted mansion so i'm very
excited to get into reading that
universal's a lot better than disney a
lot better
it is yeah well the rides are more
exciting right
now if you've never been to disney i
grew up going to disneyland in
california and disney world
so i'm just kind of like i know it is
kind of nostalgic i mean people should
go
it's still like a good experience
nostalgic yeah okay
but no [ __ ] you want to go to some
kind of
six flags magic mountain or [ __ ]
universal studios that's that's where
you want to go
i mean if you're into like really super
cool rides you want to have fun roller
coasters and stuff
this is for kids it is and old people
but the haunted mansion's still rad
though gotta say
haunted mansion and space mountain are
the only two and also the splash
mountain was good and so was the
matterhorn but i don't think they have a
matter of horn here do they
no we have big thunder mountain railroad
i've been on the matterhorn a long time
it's probably not as good as i
remembered it
because it's probably aged out it's a
good it's a good roller coaster yeah
uh pirates of the caribbean was good and
they've updated that
i actually watched a ride through i
watched a rhyme through on youtube
because i wanted to compare
i don't know why i got an off on this
kick i don't know but um
i wanted to compare like what the uh um
what the florida one and then what the
california one was
well i started out with haunted mansion
that i was curious because a lot of
people were saying oh the disneyland
pirates of the caribbean is so much
better
so i wanted i was curious to like see
like so i watched a ride through
and i will say definitively the
disneyland
california pirates of the caribbean is
way better than the florida one
ours is okay too but it's like half the
length yeah
the california was way longer another
good thing about the california one at
least when i was a kid i hadn't been
there since i was in the [ __ ]
early 80s is that the pirates of the
caribbean ride in california
in uh in california had a restaurant
connected to it called the blue bayou
room i think it was called
it was a restaurant that overlooked the
[ __ ]
entrance when the little buggies that go
into before they went to the waterfall
yeah
it was like you were in new orleans and
then
you know on the coast of new orleans in
a swamp and i love that restaurant they
had [ __ ] monte cristo sandwiches in
there which are in the cookbook
yeah you got the money because you
because you've made those a few times
[ __ ] right
there's a hard way to eat the way the
easy way
is it's a ham and swiss cheese
sandwich on french toast with [ __ ]
uh um either grape jelly or um
what's a [ __ ] what's that [ __ ] not
coriander jelly
grab jelly that's not what it is there's
something like
like grape put a little bit of power
sugar on it
another way they would do it in [ __ ]
way they would do it is they would
in uh [ __ ] man
loaded swimming the way they did it
right in disneyland is that they would
take ham
and swiss cheese and they would put it
in big old thick
texas toast and dunk it in the egg
batter and deep fry it
yeah that's how they did it and then
they'd put it on a plate they'd sprinkle
it with [ __ ]
powdered sugar on the top of it cut it
in half and then give you a side
of um what do you call the [ __ ] jenny
it's it's like grape jelly
but it's not grape it's not lingenberry
no
blackcurrant current yeah current jelly
i think it's current jelly yeah
blackcurrant is a big thing in the uk
they even have ribena which is like a
blackcurrant
drink i feel really good put the jelly
on the sandwich and eat it man she was
so good
but the thing is the money cristo now
you know in a
in a home environment most you can't
most people can't deep fry they don't
have the equipment to deep fry
they don't know much about egg batter so
you can substitute the [ __ ]
dunking the thing an egg better just by
making some french toast make some fresh
toast and maybe
it's not quite the same but it's close
enough close enough
well the well the interesting thing is
that and i was kind of researching this
when we were
you know working on that section of the
cookbook because we've made monte cristo
before but i wasn't aware but it's
actually
a variation of a french sandwich going
way back
called what the [ __ ] is it called a
croque madame or
something or rather and it's kind of
it's essentially french toast with like
ham and cheese oh
money wait is it hayden santos he says
i'm gonna make
i'm gonna make a pork butt you got any
recommendations okay
what are you gonna i'm gonna answer your
question thank you hayden what are you
gonna make the pork butt
for like yeah what's your are you making
carnitas are you making it is this
something you're gonna have a rice or
mashed potatoes or what i i can tell you
once i know more what kind of dish
you're gonna make
you know because you may worry about
[ __ ] i can make [ __ ] barbecue pulled
pork with that
he makes pork butt all the time yeah big
pork
pork butt is a good [ __ ] cut it's
like
it's still a cheap cut but it's above
shoulder shoulder's a little fattier but
i could use either one
the mexicans use either one if you make
a mexican food doesn't matter
it's like we should probably i was going
to say like
incarnate sorry okay
um you're gonna use it in a slow cooker
or you're gonna [ __ ] cook it in an
oven
um you know [ __ ] just
you can go wild with that you know uh
salt it
put it in some kind of a metal you know
if you're gonna put it in an oven or a
slow kicker just salt it
cover it with um uh roll it around in
some damn
bishop cumin a little bit of cocoa
powder and a little bit of damn
uh cinnamon that's i like it like that
then put it in a slow cooker and just
cover it just soak up that [ __ ] forever
when you get done pull
pull both well not forever but yeah and
then take a big
spoon and try to spoon out some of that
fat that'll be on the top of it
leave the fat side up that'll help you
peel the fat off the top of it
once it's done it should just fall apart
once it's done
then drain the drain fluid from it into
a [ __ ] frying pan
put all that meat in the frying pan
scalding hot burn off
all that fluid so this so that
so the uh the spice is left and it goes
into the meat
cook that meat until you at a very high
temperature you want that [ __ ] [ __ ]
sizzling when it hits
that way you get little burnt ends on
the [ __ ] pork
don't break it all up when you put it in
the pan
pull the bone out of it chop it into big
chunks
because you want some chunks when you're
going to do tacos and stuff
and then just kind of yeah you don't
want it little flakes and [ __ ] just
[Laughter]
and you want it to be [ __ ] seared
once it's done in a [ __ ] hot pan and
you're trying to reclaim those spices
out of
the spices out of that juice pour the
juice in there boil the juice off
so it starts getting thick and then put
the meat in there
the chopped meat you know what i'm
talking about they do it like that
you made i have to say you made tacos
today
out of you made a pork tenderloin that
was a pork tenderloin yeah
and you didn't we didn't do it in the
slow cooker you did it in the [ __ ]
and
you just did it in the pan right but you
just like cooked it for a really long
yeah
like in a big skillet and then he just
turned it into
when we i mean a lot of times when we
cook a big piece of meat like that
we'll just cook it with minimal spices
so then you can spice it later for
whatever application
that you want to use it for are we done
with the uh
slices well i mean did you want to talk
about i mean we already kind of
mentioned that kurt russell is possibly
the first person that's on this
which that makes it like way more
awesome and it makes it a legit case
that [ __ ] saw it from his airplane
what's up with those lights yeah he was
apparently flying his private plane to
phoenix
he said he didn't know what it was at
the time he found out later
when he looked at his flight log he's
like man that's the phoenix lights
yeah that he saw he didn't know what it
was yeah he just reported it to the uh
it was the phoenix sky harbor
international airport you saw lights on
the horizon you know unknown lights on
the horizon it's like what the [ __ ] is
this
they didn't know what they were yeah
yeah it's
uh i i just kind of yeah so i guess he
didn't know at the time because
you know um and then he when he heard
about it later on he's like oh yeah that
was
march 13th 1997. that was the same night
that that happened so i saw that [ __ ]
so it turns out that probably allegedly
he was probably the first person to call
that in which
that makes sense well like i said how
awesome would it be
if that actually was an extraterrestrial
craft and kurt russell
yeah what's the first [ __ ] person to
report it yeah
that is just like that's so perfect
that has to be true now i really wanted
to be alien he believes it was that he
believes that it was
that that it was the phoenix lights but
he didn't know what they were he saw him
at a distance
yeah he just thought it was a weird
light and he's like hey i'm saying it's
a weird light though
okay pretty much he didn't say it was
like ufo or anything no you know what it
was
well in the sense of ufo being like
alien spacecraft ufo being unidentified
flying object okay
but you know what i mean and um
yeah yeah kressel talks about it all the
time when he's in the uk
according to mango oh it's cool yeah
he's like
well i'd talk about it too if i saw that
[ __ ] and it was like all famous and
whatnot
i like crusoe across the school how can
you know
how can you know was it crustal was even
even when he was young he was an actor
from another era that really didn't
belong in hollywood i mean he was
he's kind of just a regular guy he's
kind of guy that
you know rides four wheelers and shoots
guns out on his farm and everything he's
not
not an la guy i don't think goldie is
really an la [ __ ] chick
three either i mean i think they're just
kind of like regular people i i like
i like kurt just everything i heard
about him and just
just the vibe i get you know i like
[ __ ] kurt russell
and uh i saw some like behind the scenes
footage of him and his girlfriend darren
she was uh during escape from new york
she was the one that got pulled through
the floor
by the scavengers remember her yeah yeah
that's right
and he's dressed up in his [ __ ]
snake pliskin outfit and she's in her
[ __ ]
prison [ __ ] hottie outfit and [ __ ]
and they got a photo of them just like
making out behind the scenes
they're making out like teenagers and
[ __ ] like getting ready for the next
scene and [ __ ] you know
he was evidently real hot on her it
didn't work out though evidently
well how long like him and goldie have
been together for like
forever it seems like yeah thank you
mango
crustal is the man yeah he just seems
like a nice down to earth dude
just a regular guy yeah yeah he's like
i don't want to claim him as a
southerner but he's almost southern
he's an honorable yeah he's an honorary
southerner
he's he's a real man sure
but uh no the whole thing of him uh
[ __ ]
the photograph of him and his second
girlfriend making out
in those kind of almost kind of like
punk rock out [ __ ] clothes he's got
that mac 10 hanging from his [ __ ]
shoulder
making out with her and [ __ ] and it's
like a candid shot
somebody snuck up on him to take that
picture and it just [ __ ]
was like like it's just [ __ ] the tone
of it is [ __ ]
what's up oh my goodness what are you
talking about tone of it you know i
understood it
you know i mean i was like yeah he's
just regular dude yeah
yeah well he's just like stealing a
moment yeah stealing a moment
victor says they've been together since
1947
[Laughter]
it seems like that long in hollywood
years that's a very long time yeah
tila said she loved the movie breakdown
yeah we did a review of that
real good movie that is i got it on
blu-ray yeah yeah it's good
i mean that's one of his better movies
and it's and it's like a forgotten movie
most people don't know about it
yeah if you like the duel you should
check that one out like
kind of a similar theme but you know
yeah um
dude from new york send me that i forgot
his name thank you gadgie
thanks guys no he isn't no he isn't what
what crustal isn't the man
he's not the man no i like crossover
crossover was great in [ __ ] once upon
a time in hollywood what was it called
what's fun what was him what's about a
time in hollywood yeah yeah it was a
good movie he was great in that too
i really liked that movie yeah it was
just like such a long like hangout kind
of movie
yeah but i don't know yeah i really i
really kind of got into it
did you see once upon a time in
hollywood you got to see that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] was good too
somebody says deepwater horizon was
great
yeah uh season hubley was the chick curt
married they have a kid together
okay that was the one from um that was
the one from uh
escape from new york so he's talking
about yeah i guess yeah
backdraft tango and cash i remember
seeing
i feel like i saw both of those but i
don't remember much about them
back draft or titan cash i'll have to
see those again one of these so is there
any more to talk about
do you want to talk a little bit about
lin kitay katai yeah
we're talking about it yeah i'm just
saying victor victor said yes he
is and he sent us twenty dollars he is
oh they're gonna fight
you see look at a fight thank you broke
out between [ __ ] crustle fans
and crustal detractors and who benefits
me and jenny we made 50 bucks on that
right there on that [ __ ] fight who
was the person that was giving me money
every time i said [ __ ]
i don't know and i'll say it again i say
[ __ ] cut
for her just saying come on
it's like this is going to add up very
very quickly yeah
because i kind of use that word a lot
tila says uh sorry tom which movie were
you asking me about i forgot do you
remember once upon a time in hollywood
yeah once upon a time in hollywood
yeah yeah once upon a time we saw that a
couple times ago that's a quentin
tarantino movie was on one of his
his last one and it was very good we saw
it twice in the theater
yeah and i have it on blu-ray and we
watched it once on yeah right i had the
girl from birds of prey
what was her name again margot robbie
margaret she played one of the girls who
got killed in a damn [ __ ] she's been
a ton
yeah she was also in [ __ ] i
tonya about tonya harding and i totally
want to watch that yeah let's see that
let's see that
it might you know what let me check on
um i know i saw it on something i saw it
on hulu
or amazon prime or something because i
was like flipping through and i was like
oh
i want to see that yeah but you were
like no you didn't once upon a
t all right i know you're a california
girl all right
and i don't know how you are but you
must be similar age to me
to me maybe you're probably maybe 10
years younger maybe 20 years younger i
don't [ __ ] know
you would still be close to my age even
if you were 20 years younger because i'm
eternally young
anyway you didn't even laugh jenny i
wasn't around with some crazy [ __ ] i
said what was it what did you say
nevermind anyway i was crunching all
night
i couldn't hear you once upon a time in
hollywood took me back to set
to california that i remember when i was
in the 70s and the 80s as a kid
they de-aged certain parts of california
for that movie
the cars and just the way they i don't
know if they did it with cg or what
it was pretty amazing though it was very
cool
like the old darwiner schnitzels and
[ __ ] that they had
and all the old [ __ ] and the old cars i
remember old punk rock songs yeah and it
was just like
about that place mangoes
thank you mango [ __ ] you victor crusoe
rocks 20
20 pounds everybody's saying we should
watch itania
i've been wanting to watch it for so
long after it was awesome
we'll watch it uh [ __ ] look
and it's on hulu they said in the
superhero [ __ ]
scene movie scene uh birds of prey got
shat on
uh i see why they [ __ ] on it it is not
really kind of like a modern superhero
movie kind of reminding me more of tank
girl from the 90s it was kind of a
[ __ ] throwback kind of movie
it was okay they could have done a lot
better with that movie
and you know what i think was a real pro
i like her as an actress though and she
did a really good job
um i think birds of prey would have been
a lot better if they'd given her [ __ ]
sexier costumes that were allowed
out of the damn comic books and animated
features
if she had a [ __ ] you know what i
mean um
a [ __ ] harley quinn look i think it
would have
gone over a lot better with the fans i
didn't like how i didn't like her
costumes in it
um but that movie wasn't that bad not as
bad as a lot of people thought yeah i
didn't mind it it wasn't that bad
it was entertaining i had fun watching
it was a fun movie um
i think the problem was the costumes i
think if her costume was a little
[ __ ]
edgier i think i think i think the fans
would have liked it a little better
um but she was great and once upon a
time in hollywood [ __ ] shoot
wonderful
we have a lot of good [ __ ] in there you
got [ __ ]
brad pitt who else is in that [ __ ]
everybody um
everybody did it brad pitt um the dude
that was from
leonardo dicaprio he's in it um
you got that [ __ ] girl there you go
who you got all these people
that's what i'm saying you got all these
people in it that sure was a movie with
a lot of people and that was the
movement right there
a lot of people they even had bruce lee
in it
yes not actual bruce lee that would be
really important that would have been
something if they could get actual i
have it on blu-ray we haven't watched it
on blu-ray
i thought we watched it once i'm on
blu-ray no we haven't watched it on
bluetooth oh okay
i'm kind of laughing at like mango
because he says [ __ ] you victor kressel
rocks then victor says
you gave 20 to agree with me yeah and
then mango said bugger i aimed it at the
wrong yeah
man this is a great with tom harley
amanda says i agree with tom harley's
supposed to be insanely sexy yeah that's
what i was thinking of goodness
she would look that that actress that
actress is attractive she's sexy
on her own but all the animated versions
of [ __ ]
a [ __ ] harley quinn oh okay she's in
sexy outfits so that was gadgy that said
i was the benefactor for the usage of
the c word
okay all right so thank you and you got
20 pounds thank you thank you thank you
very much
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
contacular capacious
i don't know i'm just making [ __ ] up at
this point
oh my god okay look we got to get back
to the [ __ ] case i know
no look do you want to talk about this
lady or not talk about it talk about it
i mean i don't really care that much
because we already kind of like talked
about it
skirt over it yeah so this lady here
link a tai lin could i yeah now
seven years after the initial sighting
of the phoenix lights this woman comes
forward now she's
a doctor right she started out as an
actor though
she was then like she was in like some
theater productions with like some
famous people
and then like i said probably her best
known role as florence arizona and
raising arizona
the coen brothers movie which like i
said i've just learned that today so
okay
she came forward many years after the
sighting
and said hey she's gonna let me out hi
pookie
okay and said hey i saw that [ __ ] too
but it was like
two years prior to the big sighting
so apparently she had i don't know if
this is true or not
but she had documented
this sighting which took place in 1995.
excuse me and she had written a book
called
phoenix lights a skeptic's discovery
that we are not alone which like i said
i'm pretty sure we have that book around
here somewhere
i don't remember under what
circumstances we got it but we have it
someplace
so her thing was that she lived in
phoenix or in that area right her and
her husband are both doctors
and apparently she started seeing these
weird lights
outside of her balcony like outside
their house
and she started taking pictures of it
and documenting it in what ended up
being like this 750 page journal that i
guess she kind of edited and like turned
in the book later on
but i don't know man like i've watched
this
this documentary that she made
and okay so one thing i love
is that she has the documentary which
has her like talking heads it has like
all your kind of like main players
in this case talking about it except
kurt russell unfortunately
sure i'm sure she couldn't get him but
my favorite part of this was her
reenacting
her seeing the lights outside of the
balcony you know what i mean
because they're like here's her
apartment and she's oh i'm gonna run
over to the window in my robe
and like take a picture it was like i
don't know it's just like some something
about that struck me it's very funny
like all the reenactments that she did
and like i said i didn't know that she'd
started out as an actress i knew she was
a doctor but
i didn't know that she was an actress
prior to that so
it just kind of like cracked me up that
that they later made this documentary
and she did re-enactments where i'm
gonna
i'm gonna run through this you know set
of my apartment in my robe
and we'll take pictures of these lights
outside you bought that book and you
were
you were reading it to me i was in bed
you're reading it yeah i remember that
we got a couple's chapters through it
and i was like man
[Laughter]
because it was very very wordy and it
didn't have much to do with what she saw
but a lot to do with everything else um
jason bad
i think his name is jason daddy says
death proof it's a great kurt russell
film i haven't seen death
you haven't seen death proof no which
one is that it was do you remember the
que that quentin tarantino did that
movie
uh grind house and it was two-part it
was two
movies essentially in one movie with
like fake tracks oh that over he's
looking like a rockabilly in the [ __ ]
car and [ __ ] well he's like a stunt
driver
okay yeah yeah and he like picks up
those two girls at the bar
yeah it was the same one like the first
one was planet terror and that had like
um what's a bit like rose mcgowan
with the gun leg yeah yeah i saw a bit
of that
it's weird because like i saw i don't
really i'm not a big grind house
in the theater so i saw it the way it
was supposed to be seen it was like two
movies
two separate movies with fake trailers
in the middle yeah
so i saw it like that i kind of feel
like now
they're selling them as two separate
movies that's not how i saw them
initially i saw them as one movie
grindhouse
yeah i haven't seen death proof if
anybody wants to send me death proof you
can send me death proof i'll review it
i liked it i mean i like i haven't seen
it i like actually i i really liked
grindhouse
and honestly but i thought both stories
were good and all the [ __ ]
fake trailers in the middle hilarious
okay they were hilarious
i mean you know i think rodriguez did
one like
david david june's already sending me a
whole [ __ ] thing of hook and batman
animated batman movies nice yeah that's
on the way i'm gonna watch those too
a lot of you i know that you know we we
talk about it on the show
people are uh well let's just say the
world is big into these damn marvel and
dc
superhero movies i i like i like a lot
of them not all of them but i like a lot
of them
i like some of the marvel stuff too you
know the series
but i i see so far i kind of like the
animated stuff that i saw
the animated stuff i think was a little
bit better the stories make more sense
in an animated format
well it's closer to the comic book
closer to the comic books
and that was one of the reasons why i
think in in recent times
now of course you know the [ __ ] old
superman one and two you know
[ __ ] he's unbeatable you know
[ __ ] superman too [ __ ] great too
anyway um
um [ __ ] whatever that's saying we're
saying that
yeah what was i saying i said in recent
times as far as live action stuff
i i'm just saying [ __ ] might
try to beat my ass behind it but
i like shazam i thought shazam no one's
going to beat your ass for like that
okay
the tone behind shazam was real close
to an animated feature and i just liked
it
i like i want to i want a sequel to it
you know
marvel's a little more serious i don't
understand that i think that was kind of
boring
but i liked [ __ ] shazam i liked that
first um aquaman
that aquaman was pretty good we saw yeah
it was a little cheesy but like i said
it was kind of supposed to
it was kind of meant to be cheesy yeah
like they weren't embarrassed of the
cheese i want to switch that kind of
respect i want to see the snyder cut of
this
[ __ ] you know justice league
everybody's saying it's really good
we'll see yeah we'll get around to it i
kind of want that on [ __ ] blu-ray
yeah so we can devote a whole day to
that yeah
[Laughter]
[ __ ] like that right yeah um
alex souza says i think eli roth was in
death yeah i think he might have been
now that i'm thinking about it it's been
a
long time since i've seen it but
yeah i agree that you kind of have to
see it it's really weird to me that
they're selling it as two separate
movies now because initially it was just
it was a movie it was called grindhouse
but it was two movies with trailers in
the middle yeah
you know i mean he was he was trying to
replicate the experience of going back
to the 70s and seeing like a double
feature at a drive-in
that's what he was trying to do so it
was two movies with trailers
but so so them selling them as separate
movies it's kind of just like kind of
[ __ ] up the whole experience
i'm glad i got to see that in the
theater actually sorry i just like saw
something in my notes about this
linka tay woman katai yeah am i
pronouncing it wrong every single time
okay um sorry but um i keep forgetting
like from time to time like
how you pronounce it i just saw this
thing in my notes that kind of made me
laugh because like i said remember the
documentary that i said that i was
watching and there seemed to be an
inordinate um
focus on teaching school children
that aliens were okay and that they were
friendly and not to have this like
hollywood propaganda that aliens were
mean and gonna blow us up or whatever
so i kind of feel like there was a whole
undercurrent of that so i just saw this
in my notes
i just must have skimmed over it earlier
but it says
she said in the interview for the past
five years
and this interview was a couple years
old i've been developing a comprehensive
curriculum
on the topic of you know the phoenix
lights aliens
for grades four through twelve and we'll
be releasing the groundbreaking
phoenix lights ufos and crop circles
coloring book
is that still there somebody go check i
kind of want so she became
she became a ufo freakazoid yeah and
well she has kind of the same origin
story it's like i never believed in this
kind of stuff
until that's you know so it became a way
to make some money
well yeah that's although i think she's
going to be unspoken
and then katai already had money i think
she has money well her and her husband
are both
doctors yeah so i imagine they were
probably doing it yeah
i kind of think lynn kind of liked she
liked
the attention of going on our bell and
having something to do
a lot you know but just that's just what
i'm saying
yeah i mean i don't know maybe she saw
something i don't think she saw the same
event
no a couple years prior no yeah i don't
even know if that's he's trying to
[ __ ] establish
a pattern between what she saw in the
location that she was in
in other words it's kind of like that
old hippy dippy oh well this
area is blessed this area is haunted it
would be way lights
is better must be way longer way lines
yeah it must be way lines because i'm
living here so
[ __ ] ufos are coming to me through
the intersection between all these
[ __ ] spiritual forces
that's that that sort of sounds like you
know everybody likes to feel special
right
everybody wants to live somewhere where
aliens are coming everybody wants aliens
to visit them it's because they're you
know
special badgers just saying [ __ ]
[ __ ] sakes tom just
just watch it i guess he's talking about
laughs
tina's going tom justin's [ __ ] wrong
uh grant is going to just uh okay he's
talking about arleigh
irmi david [ __ ] like june is going
about how much better the
animated universe for dc is to the live
i've heard that as well
scott says it turned the coloring book
industry on its ear
that's why that made me laugh she comes
in
28 on ebay jenny phoenix likes 28.95
yeah
yeah i'm in the wrong business
i can make a crop circle coloring book
now khan
says [ __ ] the phoenix tapes of of of
87 is a good movie almost 97.
there's been a bunch of movies like
fictional and otherwise like i said i've
seen the documentaries i don't think
i've seen any of the fictional movies
i'm trying to like look i had a list of
like them
but there was uh yeah phoenix lights we
are not alone that's a documentary
there was one called the appearance of a
man i think that was maybe
a fictional there was one people look
like a man
like a man you guys don't remember mad
tv remember the little [ __ ] what was
his name
the woman that was impersonating the
korean [ __ ] all right
i remember that i really got robbed by
saying what do you look like he look
like a man yeah but what he looks like
like a man yeah well you know yeah yeah
he had arms and hair
yeah um yeah so there was a
i guess it was a horror movie came out
in 2007 called night skies
that was a directed dvd one there was
one called
they came from outer space which was
used to be called phoenix lights the
movie
which that's kind of a dumb title the
phoenix incident
is one that came out in 2015. probably
most of these are on tubey i imagine
i just i didn't have time to watch them
i should have and the phoenix tapes 97
that's what he's talking about that's
found footage
that came out in 2016. and there's also
a another found footage science fiction
horror film released in 2017 called
phoenix forgotten
that it's about the phoenix lights man
see
this is a very famous case yeah now i'm
kind of going to watch that
so what happens in phoenix tapes 97 is
there actually aliens that come and like
probe people because
otherwise i don't i don't want to know
because
it's hard to make a horror movie out of
hey we saw some lights in the sky and
everything was cool
aliens better come out of them like
shoot people with [ __ ] death rays and
[ __ ] we saw some lights
look like a carpenter circle governor
said no man 10 years later he says no i
saw that [ __ ] too
yeah sorry i had my a dress up like an
alien to make fun of you guys
yeah air force is like we don't know
what it was
grab some flares though like we do
yeah yeah khan said he also saw that one
the phoenix forgotten
so are they good are they worth watching
you know what i mean
yeah i don't know i'm not
in horror movies i'm not a big fan other
than
obviously the classics i'm not a big fan
of like ufo or alien
horror movies i don't know why
it's just not something that's that all
that scary to me i guess yeah you know
granters asked me question for tom which
war movie is more realistic full metal
jacka or platoon
oh i haven't seen either one in a long
time i liked both of them
i liked both of those movies too
actually um
i remember seeing platoon and then when
you when they when they got to the baby
huey character
i was like man they would never they
would never let a dude like that into
the army i was wrong
there was an episode during vietnam that
was called uh
magnum mcnamara's morons
yeah mcnamara's [ __ ] [ __ ] mcnamara
who was running who was the [ __ ] he was
not the wiz kids who was running the us
army at that time he's part of that
administration
came up with a brilliant idea to take
[ __ ] basically mildly [ __ ] dudes
and [ __ ] to draft them
into the army to teach them skills and
send them into combat it was one of the
biggest military failures
of all times because almost none of
those dudes came back alive
none of them yikes oh [ __ ] low iq
soldiers did not work
in vietnam they will never work part of
it was
is that they were such a security risk
on patrol they made so much noise
because they couldn't grasp what was
going on
they were what we called [ __ ] what
they recall what you called a frag
all right as soon as a [ __ ] firefight
broke out you killed that dude
because and then say that the enemy did
it
because they were a threat to your
survival you have to have
everybody [ __ ] competent and to
understand that
noise and light discipline could mean
your [ __ ] life
because they just couldn't be quiet they
just could not be quiet
they couldn't understand what was going
on which is very unfortunate
but of course you know the federal
government and the people that run the
federal government
in the history of the united states
going back to the 1800s and all the [ __ ]
they did
in the banana republic wars and
everything like that none of them have
ever paid for their crimes
none of them [ __ ] terrible
but mcnamara should have been [ __ ]
hung for that
to take mental [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah to
take mentally
[ __ ] people and draft them into the
[ __ ] service and put them in
frontline combat
[ __ ] stupid oh no
stupid and tragic yeah this is [ __ ]
um this is this is the thinking of
[ __ ] dudes
that spent most of their lives behind
desks that don't know how anything works
just because of [ __ ] in charge
just because he has a title
that does not mean that dude knows what
he's doing all right
looking i want to get off this subject
well i mean just
i i have always my entire life i've just
lived under the assumption that people
telling me what to do have no idea they
don't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
i mean that's just a safe assumption if
you don't believe what i'm saying
just look up the [ __ ] google
mcnamara's morons
that's what it's called thank you david
yeah by the way because
david said because effort that's why
because [ __ ] it a lot of people are
recommending
the fourth kingdom which i i keep seeing
that the four yes
uh right that's where it was go back go
back go back
the fourth kind sorry not kingdom what
am i talking about
yeah the fourth kind is very good a
bunch of people the signal is actually
very good i've seen that
so yeah that is actually good but yeah
the fourth kind i keep seeing that come
up in my recommendation oh and i got i
got to
answer grandparents grandparents is a
guy i went to high school with he's an
ex-cop
all right um so to answer your question
granters
out of the two because platoon
is [ __ ] it is my boy
okay that's that's [ __ ] kubrick
chances are the kubrick is gonna be more
more uh
more reliable out of the two now
platoon was not totally inaccurate from
what i remember
but i also remembered the one that i
really liked back in those days
and was and i believe it was about one
of my units that i was in the 327 i was
in the 327th
of the 101st airborne for a while it was
a movie called hamburger hill
and i remember that one when i was in
service we loved that we thought that
that [ __ ] was very relevant i kind of
feel like a lot of people don't talk
about that when it's happening
i remember that one being good too i
remembered hamburger hill as being more
more rel more accurate
now in terms of spiritual
accuracy and art apocalypse now
the new redux cut too the new redux cut
apocalypse now because that's [ __ ]
millions man
[ __ ] jump milius is the [ __ ]
genius he understands exactly what that
shit's all about
[ __ ] apocalypse now redux cut
and [ __ ] conan the barbarian the
first one
and uh jeremiah johnson those aren't
movies man those are the movies
those three right there yeah hell yeah
they're but the thing is is that they
are they're they're not movies for all
for all all audiences they're very much
very macho although jenny liked them
yeah well see that's what i mean it's
like
they're very macho though they're more
men's lessons especially apocalypse now
and jeremiah johnson's
conan actually has a lot of lessons for
women in it
a lot if you understand the language
that was spoken
with valeria and how the fact the
[ __ ] an
evil [ __ ] group of men can hijack
femininity to gain power through this
snake cult
because it was basically men telling
women what to do
even though they're all looking for
paradise and [ __ ]
nah and then they're then it turns out
that you don't
can't grow anything so they just eat
each other
they're basically talking about cultural
marxism in a certain way
you know the frankfurt school of thought
it doesn't create it just
criticizes and then it's a circular
firing squad
and it's seems to be feminist but it
isn't men are behind it that's what
that's what that meant
remember how i tried to figure out what
it was he was talking about the egg and
the serpents and the
and the women and the cult that's what
he was talking about
yeah yeah feminism is what is exactly
what he was talking about
yeah a lot of people are uh saying
hamburger hell was uh
it's very good yeah i haven't seen it i
watched it with my dad back in the day
and i thought it was real
i haven't seen in a long time it was my
first war movie but my favorite
yeah tammy keeps saying about ghost of
war i think we might have cut we might
have reviewed that that's on netflix
right
yeah i'm pretty sure we talked about
that a little while back yeah yeah about
the soldiers that found the
the hat the haunted house some people
were telling me to watch blood diamonds
that i would like blood diamonds but i
haven't seen it yet i saw it yeah i
thought
yeah i liked it yeah i saw it on a plane
actually quite a quite a few years ago
but yeah i remember it being really good
it's gonna you know it was a long time
ago
um i wonder if jeremiah johnson is
related to felice johnson booty warrior
sure
[Laughter]
who's talking about fleece i wonder if
uh
no no no okay no there's a big
difference between
well yeah yeah i see what you're talking
about uh
but no police johnson booty warrior
forgot all about that dude he's dead now
he got out he got they freed him
he lived for a while then again they
died his booty warrioring days are wrong
i gotta say i like fleece just please
put on a great show for that
documentary okay he put on a very great
you gotta throw a good
he ended up being out with the boondock
saints or something
they ended up [ __ ] doing animated
versions of like a booty warrior
yeah well yeah and then now gramster's
hammer is asking as far as world war
ii saving private or the thin red line
i haven't seen thin red line saving ryan
was pretty good
i liked it i remember liking it i don't
think i saw the fib red line but it was
a long long long long time ago
yeah tila says then red line for her
what's eating gilbert grape
yeah no it hasn't been done yet that was
a good movie
it hasn't been done yet it's a really
good world war ii movie about the
[ __ ] pacific island fighting
the [ __ ] they have don't [ __ ] pele
lou i would do a story about peleliu
that's the [ __ ] the weird [ __ ] that i
saw when i was a kid
in these war books all that [ __ ] you
never see it now it's all out of print
semi-band [ __ ]
american soldiers with [ __ ] japanese
heads rotten
japanese heads stuck up on the front of
their [ __ ] vehicles and stuff
it was that was a weird ass mission they
could have gone around peli
but the command said nah the japanese
are on pele
so let's fight them they could have just
gone around them
and starved and cut the supply lines and
starved them but the thinking of the
time was like well the enemy's there
let's fight him
and it was totally undermined with
tunnels
tons of japanese troops [ __ ] ready to
[ __ ] fight to the death
and they all basically went insane out
there fighting each other
[ __ ] american guys were getting cut
[ __ ] captured and getting their
[ __ ] [ __ ] cut off and tortured to
death by japanese
they were [ __ ] we were burning
japanese dudes alive the [ __ ]
flamethrowers
a lot of sniper warfare a lot of
beheadings
uh dudes carrying heads around with them
and putting them around their fighting
positions
it was a descent into [ __ ] savagery
and evidently the dude the amer
and they killed every eventually they
killed every [ __ ] japanese soldier
on belly loop and evidently the american
troops
they were army troops if i remember
correctly they weren't marines
the army troops were never quite the
same i think they were kind of [ __ ]
evacuated from the theater
after that i don't think they kept them
i don't think they they told them their
time was up they sent them back
but that was something that they trying
to they're trying to bury that at that
um
several people have said that hbo made a
series called the pacific that was about
that very thing
oh yeah yeah okay so and yeah several
people said haven't you seen that no
i've seen that okay
well they're they're learning something
about it and if i remember correctly
wasn't wasn't ed wood on pelly lou
he didn't know maybe luke i think he was
yeah baby
and his cross dress and weird ass i
think i think he actually
went made it through peleliu wearing
women's [ __ ] lingerie
well that's what he said that's what he
said wearing women's lingerie underneath
his [ __ ]
his uniform terrified that he'd be
[ __ ] wounded they'd find them damn
painful
that he had me yeah i don't know if
that's true or not but that's that's
the rainbow that's the story that you
told me i think it was peli might have
been
i'd have to go back and watch all that
because i have all that um
i have that edward box that that has a
documentary about him
ed wood yeah that's a [ __ ] great
movie absolute [ __ ] masterpiece we do
we have that
i do not i've seen it a bunch of time i
saw it in the theater when it came out
i mean i love a lot of tim burton's
movies but i don't know man
ed wood i love beetlejuice i love like a
lot of these other ones but edward was
so
goofy as that [ __ ] was he was very
[ __ ] very patriotic
and uh very patriotic and very [ __ ]
battle-hardened
kind of well see that's what i mean
that's yeah that's what you have
stereotyped
you can't stereotype anybody because
everybody is a very complex human being
and wood was very complicated sweaters
shooting [ __ ] movies and [ __ ]
talking about how the authorities in the
government will tell you what you know
everything was about the government and
the government authorities
i love that he made glennar glenda as
well a lot of his movies that he made um
were basically he wanted to show
like [ __ ] that was like down with his
fetish yeah you know what i mean
yeah but then he wanted to like get
around
censorship so he would make it like
like he was like he was making some kind
of like
um movie like against that or showing
like how bad it like he made this one
called that they did on mst what the
[ __ ] was the name of that thing um
[ __ ] i'll think of it in a minute but it
was kind of like the whole message of
the movie
was that smut it wasn't even porn it was
just kind of like it was photographs of
chicks and bathing suits essentially
yeah but you know they called it smud
but they called it porn in the movie but
it's it's not
that that could cause people to be
serial killers
right uh the sinister urge that's what
yeah sinister urge
you never know when you see a pretty
[ __ ] and a photographer [ __ ] might
have to kill somebody and well yeah well
that was like the whole
theme of the movie that there was like
this porn yeah there was a porn
kind of conglomerate that was run by
this really scary woman named i think
her name is gloria
she had like these crazy [ __ ] outfits
you have to see the sinister urge
seriously the mst
version is good but the original version
is good too
and one of her henchmen was
he was so um you know
uh emotionally wrought
like by by seeing these women in
like one-piece bathing suits is
essentially what they were
that he was going out and killing
[ __ ] yeah in the park
because he was just so you know
aroused by it that he had to go kill
people
and yeah it's it's really really funny
but that's kind of like why
i think that ed wood knew what he was
doing
he's like this is a way for me to show
what passed for smut in the 50s but
still being able to show it because i'm
condemning it
yeah or i seem like the only way to show
it is to condemn it
but yeah but it's it's it's there's
ulterior motives
although glen or glenda wasn't like that
because it's really it really seemed
like glenn or glenda was like his
he was trying he was trying he was
trying to normalize [ __ ]
transvestite systems because he was a
transvestite yeah so he was trying to
normalize it by saying it's like hey
this guy they're normal people
okay which like i said that's very ahead
of its time
yeah but i think a lot of his movies he
was trying to seem like he was
condemning the [ __ ] but he wasn't really
it was like a winking
that's how he had to do it though yeah
but he's like well at the same time i
also get to show it i get to show like
all these ladies running around half
dressed and you know what i mean all
right granters asking me uh what what
who was more fierce
the world war ii japanese or the north
koreans
um the imperial japanese and the north
koreans it was a similar mindset
um during the north korean invasion
of the of the south it was like a damn
civil war most of the [ __ ] that was
happening was between the north and the
south
and both sides were massacring each
other
but when it came to [ __ ] just
absolute cruelty and just a weird [ __ ]
you know sexual assaults rapes [ __ ]
mutilations and stuff
you gotta hand it to the to the imperial
japanese
what they did in nanjing to [ __ ]
chinese women what they did
what they did in china it was [ __ ]
mind-blowing and there were there was
photographic evidence of it
of what they were doing down there uh
they were horrible
um the japanese imperial
troops got off light and they came down
real hard on the
on the germans with the nazis and stuff
when when really they were very similar
real similar um but now the japanese got
off very easy
there was a lot of [ __ ] crimes and
[ __ ] that they did
um but you know i think the reason even
back in the 40s the reason why the
japanese got off easy is
really kind of like racism in a way it
was kind of like they had lower
expectations for
non-white people they didn't hold them
to the same standards i think that was
part of it
another part of it was that japan was
going to be a strategic ally
after the war they were an industrial
hub they could have helped the united
states
so they decided to they decided to
[ __ ] kind of sweep all that [ __ ]
under the rug and
try to start a new life with japan and
uh
getting into this car industry and
making stuff you know
so it's kind of like part of their
rehabilitation i guess you could say
um why the [ __ ] why they're japanese
imperials why they
why they were the way they were what the
thinking was
it was almost kind of like a fad their
the japanese are their culture is very
really
influenced a lot by fads the next newest
thing
and at that particular time japan was
running out of damn natural resources
they had [ __ ] booming industries
china was still kind of almost in a
medieval period and from their point of
view they were the
the leaders of the of the
of the of the orient if that's what you
want to call it what they called it back
then
so they wanted to dive in and [ __ ]
get natural resources and try to make
allies
but the chinese that resisted and it
became
what you'd call in the military official
military terminology it became
a cluster [ __ ] that's what you call it
and when you have a bunch of dudes that
are armed and trying to get some [ __ ]
and honors involved next thing you know
you start
[ __ ] shooting people and killing
people and then
then there was a bunch of racial
supremacy involved with the japanese
japanese believe they were superior to
all of the races including white people
they leave all this [ __ ] conveniently
out
of the history book but if you look for
it it's right there
um but no i'd give it to the japanese
the japanese were far more deadly than
north koreans
far more they had technology a lot more
willpower
uh they would kill themselves uh in
order to they would kill themselves to
take you out
they would they were [ __ ] death
before the solder [ __ ]
now here's the weird thing the japan the
japanese today are not the same people
the guys that thought like that they all
died pretty much to the last man
they just you know that's not in them
anymore
i don't think no that's not in them
anymore the dudes that were like that
died
well i kind of feel like a you know a
lot of the people that did that kind of
[ __ ] are dead now yeah they all died
they did yeah david june is talking
about unit 731 which actually i didn't
want to do a show about that
tammy is bringing up the um going back
to movies she's bringing up the
subspecies
series i actually have been wanting to
do a movie rush effective on that i
think it's been in the poll once or
twice
because i think the first subspecies is
actually on
2b or hulu i know i saw it on there
so i put it in the in the poll and it
didn't win but i do actually want to get
around to doing
at least the first subspecies movie i
know there's like a whole [ __ ]
series of them because i actually really
liked at least the first one
um japan victor says japan is definitely
a bucket list destination
so many kit kats why do they have
all the best flavors of kitkats we don't
have
you know what i mean and it's weird that
that that's kind of what they're known
for nowadays they have like the green
tea
kitkats the red bean kitkats the matcha
kitkats
they have all these crazy like [ __ ]
flavors and you can order them and stuff
we only have chocolate white chocolate
dark chocolate
maybe chocolate mint you don't see a lot
of those
now grandpa has asked me the united
states and china destined for conflict
and what do you say destined for
military conflict
over taiwan um i would say
probably that's the i would say at one
time
that would but not anymore the united
states
basically lost against china um
the united states is not headed will not
be a future superpower and china will
the time for america is over um empires
last about 200 years
we've passed that mark the united states
is too divided to continue
it will be kind of like the roman empire
where it divided into like a [ __ ]
eastern and western empires it'll be
like that um
too many of the elites have invested in
china so it's
it's its success is insured at least
for the time being but but you have to
understand i'm talking about
success from the point of view of the
chinese
um that's still a developing country in
a lot of ways
the united states will develop those
develop down a different path
being a superpower is costly and
inefficient
and unsustainable because you have to
have [ __ ] troops occupying all
we still got troops in korea we got
[ __ ] troops in japan
we got them all over in the [ __ ] we
got them all over europe
to what to defend them against what the
soviet empire
it's it's more of a scam than anything
else
and uh you know we're all up in the
middle east and the whole afghan
thing you know we mysteriously now
control the afghan [ __ ] poppy fields
and the cia controls them and black
funding and
nah it's just it
then our leaders are getting older and
older and more incompetent
and it's just showing all the signs of a
failed uh
uh showing all the sides of a of a dying
empire
it's not gonna last much longer okay
what else
a bunch of people have talked about how
they want to go to japan it's one of
their bucket list destinations like i
said
i would actually expensive i would but i
would actually like to go to japan
if you want to go to japan for a lot
less you'd have a lot more
a lot more fun if you just went to korea
let's go down to seoul well
i wouldn't don't mind going there too
yeah seoul korea is a lot a lot more fun
a lot i'm gonna we'll go to korea if you
want to
it's fun you know it's fun and it's a
lot they're not really used to tourists
so you know it's not like they're you're
you're it's not like you're stinking up
the joint you know
and it's it's it's just and
and it's [ __ ] like one-third the
price maybe one-quarter of the price
danny says i wish america had the exact
same vending machines that japan
has over there they do really they i
mean
i gotta respect their [ __ ] vending
machine game man they have vending
machines for everything
i love that um but yeah i mean you know
i would i actually wouldn't mind going
to
i wouldn't mind going to korea yeah
korea is better than japan if you ask me
adam wilder says seoul is on the list as
well yeah
i mean yeah victor says japan
chile new zealand i've yeah honestly
i've actually wanted to go to australia
and or new zealand for like a really
long time um
you know so that's kind of on the bucket
list as well there's [ __ ] man there's
like a bunch of places in [ __ ]
europe that i haven't gone yet that i
want to go i want to go to france i want
to go to italy
you know i haven't there's a ton of you
know i've been to the uk but that's
about it
and um so i kind of feel like there's a
lot of places there i haven't been
um you know i don't know but that you
know what it i know this is really sad
but like the only the only thing that
like cause we
we were talking about going to japan or
korea you know one of these days
the only thing that's really kind of
bumming me out about it is how long that
[ __ ] plane ride is
oh man i mean the plane ride from here
to the uk
is depending on which way you're going
is anywhere from seven and a half to
about nine hours and even that was just
like making me climb up the [ __ ]
walls
so i can't imagine a plane ride
like 12 hours long or [ __ ] man i'm gonna
have to do it in like legs
because i can't sit on a plane that long
i don't i really don't like flying and
it really stresses me out
and so it's like i was it's like can we
just fly for a couple hours and then
like sit down and let like let me run
around
like on the ground for a little while
then we'll get on get back on and like
be on there for another couple hours
sitting on a plane for like seven to
nine hours i just oh
it's it's really really hard for me but
yeah
uh 60s ram says australia is beautiful i
grew up there in the 1970s
i was oh thank you victor for jenny's
travel fund
yeah i'll get there one of these i used
to travel a lot more than i did around
the us around you know
like i said i've been where have i been
new york i've been to philadelphia i've
been like i'm the east coast i've been
out west i've never been to california
but i've been to colorado been in new
mexico
kind of like some other places out there
but you know
amanda smith i've done 18 hours on a
single plane ride i
oh man i you know what i would have to
be
drugged or just completely [ __ ]
shit-faced drunk
you know what i mean just so that could
i sleep or i'd be too worried
about i don't know i i don't like
i don't mind when um we're flying over
land
it's not that bad but flying over the
ocean
like you know going from florida to the
uk it's like
it was almost all over the atlantic
ocean and that really really stressed me
out
and especially because the the flight
that i used to take over there all the
time was overnight
so you couldn't see anything it was just
all darkness
and it was just darkness and ocean thank
you victor
yeah for jenny's travel fun yeah because
i was
david june says damn victor how about
you give me a couple bucks
yeah and it's like tila saying there's
so many places in the u.s yeah it's like
there's a lot of places in the u.s that
i'd like to go as well
like i said i've been to new york city
i've been to dc i've been to virginia
i've been to maryland i've been to
philly i've been to uh santa fe
i've been to denver like i've been up in
the mountains in denver that was
gorgeous
um you know well especially for me
because i grew up in florida which if
you don't know we don't have any
mountains in florida it's completely
flat it's all at sea level
and you know palm trees beaches [ __ ]
like that but
so i had never seen snow-covered
mountains
and i went to visit my sister used to
live in denver she's she lives in
atlanta now
but she lived in denver for a long time
and i went out to visit her
and i had never seen a mountain that was
covered with snow
in the summertime i think it was
[ __ ] may or june when i went out
there and there was still snow all over
the mountains
and that just blew my [ __ ] mind yeah
and also it blew my [ __ ] mind that i
was at
on a mountain and that the clouds were
underneath me
i just i thought that was so [ __ ]
cool man yeah you know what i mean and
we didn't go
like super super high i think it was
like 11 000 feet or something like that
i just grew up doing it so that it
didn't really yeah i understand he's
talking about
i think it crashed again did it crash
yeah
not still going here okay well maybe
maybe it'll come back maybe we ought to
end the show anyway because it's almost
time for me to um
do so oh we got more money got more
[ __ ] people victor said there you go
david
he gave it to me
we'll send it to you just like give me
your paypal
oh my god all right what the hell is
going on here i don't know is it crashed
again not here
okay but no i came back you came back
okay now i'm kind of worried about it we
haven't had this problem in a long time
in like a couple of weeks
maybe the aliens are doing it yeah
aliens don't like us talking about them
even though we aren't even talking about
the aliens anymore
yeah graham said he agreed with me the
whole timeline
yeah don't you don't want to get upset
about any of this [ __ ] [ __ ] this is
just
this is just a normal thing that i
consider myself
i'm just happy that i was a [ __ ]
american soldier and i [ __ ]
was a part of something that one day
will go down in history as some kind of
legendary nation like ancient rome or
the soviet union
or carthage or something you know that
was good enough that i was a [ __ ]
soldier from that
you just need somebody to make a a
statue of you like on spartacus and a
block and then you're dead right right
right
but now with your name and stuff carved
in there i'll make one for you if you
want
the way the way [ __ ] goes now i see
myself as a southerner and a floridian
and that's all i'm worried about my
local area and that was the way well
that went back into history
and that's the way it looked in the
soviet union and the [ __ ]
[Music]
way it looked and all this other they
don't want me talking no ccd
it's still running here though okay it's
still running well just let me know as
far as it's if it's going there then
it might be maybe just david just sent
us another two dollar
uh mike's got crashed so i can't yeah
that's all it is okay
so thank you thank you again thank you
very much david
so we should try to send each other
money like yeah that's like really funny
victor says it's crashing because i'm
back
and you may want to close this out i got
hamburgers and [ __ ] ready to go anyway
oh you do okay yeah i got a hammer
little bitty tacos like [ __ ] 12 hours
ago how long ago was that
that was a long time ago it's time to
eat i think i think i had that at 11
this morning so i haven't eaten since
then
we don't even know what time it is we've
been streaming a long time we did
complete the show we got two points
two uh we got two big pieces what is
that about an hour on this one
yeah it's an hour and ten minutes okay
now we should go ahead we should go
ahead and close it out it's good to see
you guys we will uh be back when
sunday sunday we'll be back soon we'll
either we'll either do a cooking show or
we'll do a matinee where we talk about
the first episode of the new
creep show series okay season yeah go
check out the new creeps they just
dropped the new the first because
they're doing it like one every week
yeah it's not all it's on shutter yeah
so yeah it's seasoned
if you're not subscribed to shutter
you're [ __ ] yourself shutters like
what three dollars a month
no it's like i think it's six dollars a
month i pay 59
a year yeah and i got a free shirt one
of the best streaming services out there
it's up there with netflix and they add
new [ __ ] every week yeah
old [ __ ] new [ __ ] like i said they're
not paying me yeah we're plug and
shutter and they don't we don't work for
them but
that's that's but they just dropped
april first they just dropped the
first episode of the season two of creep
show so we might talk about that on
matinee
or we or we might do a cooking show on
sunday
all right t we'll see you around she
says great show yeah well uh tomorrow we
might go out and do some fun [ __ ]
because it's saturday
but we'll be back on sunday at 3 p.m
eastern standard time
yeah yeah we'll probably go to
mannequins you want to go to mannequins
and said i have her
we'll see okay imani said that to tell
us next time she goes to mannequin
next time we go to mannequins because
she's oh yeah because she's madness is
closer and we already went to ivar
that's true i was saying that i have
more fun at eyebrow though that's true
that is true we'll see on saturday
we're going to start these hamburgers
all right we're going to have some
hamburgers yeah
so thank you everybody for dropping by
thank you all for your generous
donations
uh i know we didn't talk about we talked
about the phoenix lights mostly it's not
like a
hugely complicated case or anything like
that but yeah we will see you guys on
sunday afternoon and until then remember
like share subscribe blah blah all the
regular [ __ ]
and we'll see you guys later bye